BRAND-NEW EPISODE OF
"TUCKER CARLSON TODAY" ABOUT
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN AFGHANISTAN
PAIRED HERE AS PART OF IT.
♪ ♪
>> GIVING THEM LEGITIMACY ON THE
WORLD STAGE, OBVIOUSLY WE ARE
LEAVING IN DEFEAT.
WE RUSHED, WE HAVE THE SEAL
TEAM, DON'T RUSH TILL YOU'RE
DEAD.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE DID.
>> Tucker: DON'T RUSH TO YOUR
DEATH.
>> THAT MEANS EVALUATE THE
SITUATION, TAKE A BREATH.
MAKE A GOOD CALL FOR THE GUYS
YOU ARE COMMANDING.
IN THIS CASE WE HAVE 20 YEARS TO
PREPARE FOR THIS MOMENT, AND WE
DID IT ABOUT THE WORST THAT YOU
CAN POSSIBLY DO IT.
LET'S GIVE EVERYONE THE BENEFIT
OF THE DOUBT AND SAY, SINCE
APRIL WE COULD PREPARE.
EVEN FROM APRIL TO NOW.
WE DON'T KNOW HOW MANY WERE IN
THE COUNTRY, WHERE THEY WERE, AS
CITY TO CITY STARTED TO FALL,
PROVIDENCE AFTER PROVIDENCE
STARTED TO FALL TO THE TALIBAN.
WE DID NOT MAKE ANY MOVES TO TRY
TO LOCATE AMERICAN CITIZENS IN
CASE WE NEEDED TO EVACUATE THEM.
IN CASE THE TALIBAN TOOK OVER
THE COUNTRY, AND YOU CAN SEE IT
AS WE CAN INTO JUNE AND JULY, AS
WE GET INTO AUGUST, AND THEN
EVERYBODY IN THE WHITE HOUSE
GOES INTO VACATION AND RELIES ON
THEIR EMAILS AND THE FALLS, AND
WE HAVE GIVEN OUT STRATEGICALLY
ADVANTAGEOUS DECISIONS, BUT ONCE
AGAIN THAT E1, E2, E3, THE
JUNIOR OFFICER IN THE
ADVANTAGEOUS POSITION YOU CAN
PUT THEM IN, AND IT WAS A
COMPLETELY UNNECESSARY.
IF YOU APPLIED COMMON SENSE TO
THE PROBLEM.
>> Tucker: SO THIS HAS BEEN MY
OBSESSION FOR THE LAST WEEK AS
SOMEONE WHO WAS NEVER IN
BOY SCOUTS, I DON'T KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT MILITARY
STRATEGY.
IT'S BECAUSE YOU SHOULD HAVE
GIVEN IT TO THE BOY SCOUTS.
>> Tucker: THAT'S KIND OF THE
POINT I AM MAKING.
THEY DON'T EXIST ANYMORE.
THEY ARE BIGOTS.
THE MISTAKES WERE SO OBVIOUS,
EVEN I CAN UNDERSTAND THEM, BUT
THEY MADE THEM ANYWAY.
SO THEN YOU ASK, WHY IS THAT?
IT'S NOT ONE OR TWO MISTAKES, OR
A SERIES, THIS IS AN
UNINTERRUPTED CHAIN OF MISTAKES,
WHAT DO YOU THINK THIS?
>> IT'S A SNOWBALL, WHEN ONE
ERROR TURNS INTO MULTIPLE
ERRORS.
>> Tucker: AND THE PLANES
CRASH.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
WE CAN GO BACK TO 2001 TO START
SEEING THE SNOWBALL TAKE EFFECT.
AND THEN IT PICKS UP SPEED HERE
IN MID-APRIL WHERE WE GET TO
WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
AND WE LEFT DOGS BEHIND, AND WE
LEFT ALL THESE WEAPONS BEHIND,
WHICH, THAT IS JUST --
SO WE ARMED TO THE ENEMY WE HAVE
BEEN FIGHTING FOR THE LAST 20
YEARS, EVEN THOUGH WE CONFLATED
THE ENEMY, TALIBAN HARBORING
AL QAEDA, AL QAEDA, WE KIND OF
DUMBED THEM TOGETHER.
WE DID NOT UNDERSTAND TRIBAL
NATURE OF THINGS, HOW THEY
CHANGE SLIDES AND MOVE AROUND.
WE DID NOT QUITE GET THAT.
SO WE ENDED UP GOING TO WAR TO
CRUSH AL QAEDA, OKAY, AND THEN
WE WANTED TO DEGRADE, I THINK
THE EXACT WORDING FROM THE
NATIONAL SECURITY TEAM BACK IN
2001 WAS THAT WE WANTED TO
DEGRADE THE MILITARY CAPABILITY
OF THE TALIBAN.
THAT'S HOW IT STARTED OFF.
THEN THE TALIBAN GOT CONFLATED
WITH AL QAEDA AND WE STARTED
FIGHTING AL QAEDA, AND THEN IT
WAS OUR ENEMY FOR THE LAST 20
YEARS.
AT THE SAME TIME WE ARE NATION
BUILDING.
AT THE SAME TIME WE ARE SHIFTING
FOCUS TO ANOTHER WAR IN THE
REGION THAT IS DRAINING
RESOURCES FROM AFGHANISTAN.
SO BECOMES THIS QUAGMIRE IS THE
BEST WAY TO DESCRIBE IT, AND
THEN WE GET TO WHAT WE ARE
SEEING TODAY WHERE WE ARE NOW
NOT JUST ELEVATING THEM ON THE
WORLD STAGE BECAUSE WE HAD TO
LEAVE, BUT WE ARE ALSO ARMING
THEM AND WE ARE ALSO RECOGNIZING
THEM AS A LEGITIMATE GOVERNMENT.
SO, OKAY.
THEY ARE BETTER ARMED, BETTER
TRAINED, AND BETTER SITUATED ON
THE WORLD STAGE THAN THEY WERE
BEFORE 9/11.
WHICH I THINK IT'S A HARD PART
FOR VETERANS, FOR PEOPLE THAT
FOUGHT THERE AND PEOPLE THAT ARE
DEALING WITH THAT EMOTIONAL AND
PHYSICAL TRAUMA ON THE
BATTLEFIELD.
THAT'S WHY THE SUICIDE HOTLINE'S
ARE RINGING OFF THE HOOK RIGHT
NOW.
BECAUSE VETERANS ARE LOOKING
BACK AND SAYING, WAIT A SECOND,
ALL OF THOSE THINGS THAT I JUSTT
DID I SACRIFICE FOR?
>> Tucker: YES.
>> WHAT DID I GIVE MY LEG FOR?
WHAT DID THE FAMILY ON MY FRIEND
GIVE THEIR SON OR THEIR DAUGHTER
FOR IF WE JUST ARMED THIS
TALIBAN THAT IS FIGHTING OVER
THERE IN 2006,-10, '11, '12,
WHATEVER IT WAS.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THEY TAKE
THAT RAGE AND THEY CHANNEL IT IN
A WAY THAT MOVES THE BALL
FORWARD FOR THE REST OF THEIR
COUNTRY, WHICH MEANS NOT
TAKING -- NOT ROBBING THEIR
FAMILY OF THERE TOMORROW,
BECAUSE OF THE HORRIBLE THINGS
WE ARE SEEING, AND TAKE THAT